and with election day tomorrow a lot of
political candidates are making their
last pitch to voters but tonight one
local candidate is claiming her
political signs have been vandalized
even going as far as filing a lawsuit
against those who she believes are
responsible Madison Kimbrough joining us
now live from Henderson City Hall with
that story
Henderson city council candidate Carrie
Cox speaking out tonight in regards to a
campaign that she says has been targeted
and she believes that one of the people
responsible is her opponent Trish Nash
on Friday I followed filed a lawsuit
against the association and want to
proceed with that as there really have
been damages to my reputation it's been
incredibly difficult for my family
Henderson city council candidate Carrie
Cox sharing with eight news now that she
has taken legal action against the Las
Vegas Realtor Association she claims
that their political action committee
released Flyers about her that she says
are nothing but slander there were two
mailers that were received by many many
residents one accused me of being
extreme left and one accuse me of being
extreme right and it really created a
big deal among voters it all links back
to the Las Vegas realtors association my
opponent is a realtor she's a commercial
residential broker here in town Cox
referring to her city council opponent
Trish Nash Cox claims that Nash's
husband had been involved in taking down
her campaign signs along with paying off
other people people to do so that of
which a police report was made and
charges have been filed against him as
well he actually sent a picture and a
text message to me about some of the
signs and then we also have had homeless
people report to police that they have
actually been paid or coerced to take
down my signs eight news now spoke with
Trish Nash over the phone about the
allegations and lawsuit Nash says it's
unfortunate such accusations would be
made against her and her family I found
out this evening that now she's accusing
me of
hiring homeless people to remove her
signs all of the allegations
from Carrie Cox in regards to her signs
are completely unfounded and untrue and
I have run my campaign with integrity
and transparency
I also reached out to the Las Vegas
Realtor Association who shared with me
that they had no idea that a lawsuit had
been filed now tomorrow locals will cast
their final vote for either Nash or Cox
for the Henderson city council ward 3
seat reporting live here in Henderson
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now